summer league partie 2 on a vu dans la
partie 1 les performances de divers
joueurs durant cette ligue d'été 2022
soit routier ou sophomore on a tellement
parlé de tigane murray de jabbari smith
de taris zone on vous invite à retourner
écoutez c'est ce premier épisode
l'épisode 2 on va continuer puisque en
fait on a vu plein de matches enfin en
l'occurrence ben et pubs ont vu
plusieurs matches salut les gars
on va essayer de voir qui sont les
joueurs qui ont changé ou alors qu'on
essaye de changer dans cette summer
league quel est le travail des frontaux
france avec les prospects qui soit
rookie aux sophomores c'est la partie de
du podcast sommet brics est parti
[Musique]
donc
glissante tôt ce n'est déjà fait la
meilleure
je peux parler de glisse un taux
cependant pendant des heures à moi aussi
non non on va parler de 10 ans tous à
parler de la première partie mais
non on parle des gagnants on parle des
gagnants de cette summer league qui sont
les trail blazers de portland au ring
pour la bague summer league le trophée
de mvp c'était pour qu'ils gagnent
murray une qu'est ce que tu as aimé chez
les blazers en termes d'utilisation de
joueurs développement de ce kit
on a vu une équipe j'avais pas mal de
sophomore c'était des équipes un peu
plus favorite entre qui peut-être ce que
ça vaut dans summer league et ea la
blessure terrible de chez dunlop dès le
départ au bout de 7 minutes donc il y
aurait beaucoup d espace pour des
joueurs saveurs small samphel
voilà là effectivement on est sur du
secret bien gardé
et du coup sa part mis à certains
d'autres mecs de se mettre en avant
notamment la délivrance pour kirin
johnson qui a pu récupérer le ballon
après une première année compliquée aux
clippers et un deuxième joueur qui s'est
vraiment beaucoup mis en avant cette
photo à droite faute de l est saoul qui
avait fait deux ans et les sioux qui
l'an dernier scrat une place au fur et à
mesure et qui a été imposée au centre du
dispositif ces deux joueurs là ont
particulièrement brillé pour les
blenders
qu'elle le quitte pour aller plus loin
est-ce qu'ils qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils
pourraient avoir des minutes ans l'année
prochaine sachant que porte quand on a
des ambitions gagner des matches
kim johnsson il a montré contre à moité
des siens aux jeune femme tu as utilisé
sur le toit de sa jeep a retrouvé le
joueur explosif mais je vous râlerez
siffler le slasher de tennessee alors
mes petits sacs un space in particulier
ce coach barnes et un contexte
spécifique mais qu on a eu on a vu un
joueur qui est développé beaucoup un tir
à trois points et ça ça va être vital
pour lui pour pouvoir exister un aspect
singh nba le défenseur pas de souci mais
va falloir exister loin du ballon avec
des mini l'art d'avec
notre amie simone vernis simons avec
peut-être jeune sorcier jour un jour
lecture amis wang wang donc voilà on a
eu un mec qui a pu tirer un trois points
et portrait d'un watt ford on n'a pas
utilisé le joueur comme un simple posant
d'écran ce qu'il était l'an dernier mais
on a exploité ses capacités à jouer
poste bas sur un ace match genre du
switch pick and roll 1,4 qu'on retrouve
en nba on a revu ce ce corps puissant
dominant post pas capables de faire la
différence dans rouler son vis-à-vis et
de finir avec éthique c'était près du
panier est donc juste le fait de
remettre le jour dans ses forces
universitaire et de pas l'utiliser comme
n'importe quel mec comme n'importe quel
mec en nba parce que on fait tous en nba
faire du piano obtiennent le pick and
roll et après derrière tu vois pas le
ballon bah c'est bon pour le
développement du joueur est dans une
équipe qui effectuera des ambitions mais
tu ya beaucoup de jeunes ça va peut-être
permettre d'avoir un mec ce mec là qui
sort du lot ça implique un strachan a
un sens qui a rod pas trop autour de la
peinture il en avait un sur le terrain
je voulais en venir ici ben et c'est
peut-être la grosse satisfaction côté
rookie choisi au second tour cette année
oui
je pense parler de luca gaza allez on
lui parlait déjà barré walken mais oui
il y avait déjà barré wacker aussi sur
le terrain culturel qui ont montré de
très belles choses des choses qu'on
avait vu à
[Musique]
colorado cette année mais que
hymne à la joie qui physiquement
transformer les beaucoup de joie qui
profitent du du
la période avant le
perdre du poids ça fait en sorte qu'ils
beaucoup plus mobile puis l'ont utilisé
je sais pas c'est qui qui est qu
utilisent j'ai juste parcequ'il
entraîneur dé des intérieurs
qu'ils étaient à l'entraînement de
l'intérieur pour la somalie mais l'autre
est impressionnant moi je n'ai eu débat
des notes possibles surtout les a tous
les intérieurs dont jean marie qui est
capable de bouger qui est capable de
prendre des tirs en mouvement qui est
capable d'aider en défense aussi ce que
j'ai vraiment beaucoup beaucoup aimé ce
qu'on avait peut-être un peu moins vu
en fait on l'avait vu mais il avait un
peu le délit de
le délit de concombres comme on dit chez
tous dire qu'il avait une bibliothèque
on
combine souffler il soufflait beaucoup
sur la des métallos sur ses jambes c'est
ce qui m'a vraiment marqué en somme le
luxe à quel point ils étaient légers se
déplaçait bien et pour un joueur que ce
qu'il sait a comme jabberwock qui très
important mais très simple c'est
important d'être capable de bien bouger
de bien exécuter bio exécuté à merveille
en sommeil mais en fait il avait pris il
avait pris beaucoup de points entre
l'année une et l'année deux passes
contre colorado il et il sort du bon
sixième homme avec une équipe assez
expérimentés et on voit des flashs
défensif impressionnant moi c'est alan
qui me kim moyens dessus comme souvent
il a des des bons joueurs un peu caché
que c'était elle me dit regarde je
boirai walker c'est vraiment un
potentiel défensif excitant qui peut
être premier tournant prochain cette
année il est dans une équipe un peu plus
bordélique moins expérimenté il prend
énormément de toi il fait n'importe quoi
et on voit un mec trop gras et on disait
plusieurs fois le prennent déjà barré
volcan fait mention sa seule limitation
cepal pas son jeu c'est sa capacité à
rester debout fait des wings de poulet
première le lendemain de sa signature de
contrats il offre je crois il achète 200
ou 300 weeks de poulet pour eux pour
finir ça intrigue sponsorisés à d'accord
ok mais je lui avais fait un drôle de
fonctionner sur un stage parce qu'ils
savaient qu'ils sponsorisent et tu vois
là
alors après c'est une leçon à retenir
pour nous aussi c'est à dire qu'on est
un mec est un tout petit peu trop gras
tu peux quand même faire confiance à un
staff nba pour se dire lui on va
l'affiner et du coup il faut essayer
d'imaginer quel à quoi peut ressembler
le joueur dans cette mobilité nouvelle
lui donner c'est cette perte de poids
mais d'où l'importance de parler aux
joueurs de la brune conversation avant
dans le processus sa voix quel genre de
jouant ses savons si c'est un vecteur de
chaos dans une équipe où c'est juste
quelqu'un qui souhaite avoir une
certaine structure avoir à avoir des
certain mental pour être capable
d'évoluer
à mon avis dans trois ans vous regardez
sa part nous sommes demandé pourquoi
payton watson avait été choisi à
barrie walker effectivement pourrait
être un style d'autant que la rotation
intérieure de portland est pas non plus
hyper riche s'il peut gratter des
minutes avec une blessure ici un repos
en back to back là c'est pas un scénario
improbable j'ai tendance à être très
économique sur l'utilisation du mot
style mais ça c'est oui voilà
généralement un gars qui met cinq points
par fred
c'est non mais voilà je comprends ce que
tu veux dire mais en l'occurrence là
c'est vraiment fin de second tour
normalement temps n'attend rien
donc s'y produit
paolo bancaire au
premier choix de la draft mais saviez
vous quiz qu'est ce que est ce que vous
avez vu une différence entre le paulo
fine gueule fort
donc pas au dauphin de march madness qui
avaient beaucoup la balle à duke contre
ces cookies arkansas contre d'internât
et le paulo summer league en landau
magic
on a vu un joueur encore une fois très
collectif je pense que c'est ce qui a le
plus marqué les gens c'est sa capacité
de passe rapidement on a vu le mec
passeurs qui fait tourner tout le monde
alors lui venait pour kiffer n'a pas
joué tous les matches il s'est assez
bâtards été jouée en a joué 2 3
on a revu dans les défauts un joueur qui
refusait des tirs à trois points et ça
c'est encore un peu chiant il va falloir
vraiment bossé dessus comme ça notamment
sur les pick n pop ou les renversements
maintenant on a on a constaté que le mec
et même face à des joueurs plus vieux
mais c'est sûr qu'au texte est pourri
mais face à des joueurs plus vieux nba
un gars qui va dominer physiquement donc
je pense qu'il ya paulo à a été lui même
il la rassure quelque chose qu'il était
il a montré que peu importe le niveau de
compétition il était bon et il faut
vraiment travailler ce tir et on parle
de l'investissement défensif mais encore
une fois cela c'est de la summer league
donc je passe pas et l'hyper choqué s'il
fait pas la troisième rotation défensive
pour pour ce pur se troue et notamment
s'il laisse tirer une ligne à ce qu'ils
étaient à trois points sur un tir
décisif en lui disant bah tu sais pas je
souhaitais normalement et
juste drôle et c'est le contexte bon
enfant qui fait kiffer l'état c'était
une belle fin de match et choula août à
nîmes i ask état on n'a pas évoqué hier
quand on parlait de sacramento fel qui a
fait une belle somme les chouchous
envergure de longue date on n'y as keita
qui progresse d'année en année et qui
continue en fait à chaque fois qu'on le
voit il a progressé bon signe le
portugais avec des prospects portugais
kanak dans les années à venir tête sur
une vraie équipe du portugal seniors
d'ici quelques années assure des je
parle pas de calais view ce temps
je pense que tout ce temps
il a faim en gros si son shoot rentrer
il est bon et si son shoot rend pas il
n'est pas bon quoi et le premier match
il a mis 6 3 points et puis après il ya
7 2 sur 18
donc caleb écoute
là de quoi jouer en nba il va falloir
juste être à droite
effectivement ils devraient avoir des
shoots pas trop difficile s'il arrive à
gratter des minutes orlando spain équipe
avec 1000 shooter nous
le gros dossier de ce podcast c'est ok
ici
parce que
vous avez mis le rookie déjà et puis et
puis parce que chet williams ousmane
bien que des noms maintenant il parle
quand ce parti est bellery
m et l'utilisation de pièges oui
j'aimerais l'utilisation de chet qui
était un peu à l'image de l'utilisation
de decaux qui s'y fait un peu tout le
monde le tout le monde bouge tout le
monde tout le monde est dynamique tu
cherches on lui a donné des
responsabilités avec le ballon dès le
départ il en est accordée vraiment très
bien je crois qu'on a fait beaucoup de
2,2
de corps pour un rien de sa
confrontation avec kenny l'ofen du nord
la superstar de la sauver les collines
kent il entonne junior qu'on avait
laissé seul en un contre un contre jets
au périmètre des lofton sens n'est
donnée absolument accords joue à caen
joizil de défoncer
jet je crois que défensivement parlant
ça a été correct je pense qu'il doit
voir qu'il va devoir s'affirmer un peu
plus sur le terrain spécialement qui va
y avoir tout les aigles et les
extérieurs hennebicq va aussi lui
défoncer la gueule mais qui devrait être
qu'il va devoir jouer un peu plus au
périmètre mais je crois qu'ils sont à ce
point joueur qui va qui va s'illustrer 1
contre eux défensivement mais non moi je
trouve qu'il ya vraiment un bon
je trouve vraiment qu'il
qui a donné la meilleure version de chet
que qui aurait pu donner à 20 tirs à
trois points
alors
apprenons sa place sur le terrain
je crois que leo qui s'ils manquent un
peu de structure puis il m'a paru comme
ceux golog qui est prêt à prendre ce
problème en mai c'était bien aussi utile
de le faire jouer avec josh qui dit un
petit peu
près de l'autre les automatismes alors
ça ça rendait les choses faciles pour
les deux
c'était bien pour chat d'abord si sa
puberté abat clairement quand important
de bol com
ouvre beaucoup de choses et on a vu
dieuze qui dit qui a survolé la summer
league clairement il a pris du gabarit
de la puissance donc c'était c'est
exceptionnel toi tu disais beaucoup car
gonzaga on n'avait pas tout vu de chat
anglaise qu'il avait bien jusqu'à
montrer parce qu'un tel dispositif et je
pense que son premier match et c'est de
nous rappeler ça aussi il arrive prend
des actions effectivement il va un peu
de poste bas il met des gros fait de way
point des gros titres là-dessus et chaud
s'il aime qu'il a fallu de rappeler aux
gens en disant je suis pas que un mec
très fin qui va tirer à trois points et
je pense à tracter cet axe a fait et on
a vu parfois trop facilement et sept
hommes gagnent qui effectivement faisait
pick and pop qui tiennent peuple et j'ai
aimé que de temps en temps on vient de
lui rentrer dans le dit vas-y va en bas
des sens mais un peu d'intensité fait
attention à tes écran parce qu'il y en
avait beaucoup qui était pas très bien
posée alors qu'il s'est déjà très bien
le faire normalement et moi j'étais
assez rassuré sur cette summer league
des châteaux nous mêmes parce que on a
pu voir que ok s'ils avaient une idée
avec lui on a pu voir que ce qui allait
lui donner beaucoup de choses et ses
axes de progression que le joueur est
rentré clairement là dedans
effectivement il ya l'air d'avoir déjà
une bonne ambiance avec
les plus vieux même si long que vingt
ans les plus vieux comme jazz qui dit
comme ça et qu'ils ne le voir et c'est
donc tu trouvais ça bien et puis il ya
ce truc de il a fait des stats là peu
près qu'on attendait il n'a pas été
énorme mais il a été plutôt bon il assez
grosses stats en protection de certains
il a aidé son équipe à gagner ce sera
exactement sur les stades avancés je
crois que c'est le deuxième meilleur des
deux roues qui
j'ai beaucoup aimé en périphérie le fait
que jay lane williams est une jeune
guide et se font beaucoup amusé avec lui
sur le terrain
c'est comme un peu pour ces deux joueurs
là conduire une voiture de luxe puis
pour ça pour moi c'est la preuve d'un
cocker un lieu du leadership depuis que
deux lycées où se placer sur le terrain
glisse et comment es tu puisses et
interagit avec important
et puis c'est ce qu'il faut faire avec
lui le
le faire lui donner du temps de jeu sur
ses forces mais aussi de temps en temps
la vue voilà tu as le droit de prendre
un rebond pousser la balle est allée
prendre un flop à trois points si on
monte pas sur quoi le droit de monter la
balle en fête a le droit de faire des
choses avec le ballon de temps en temps
si tu la perds pas en quoi et même si tu
la perds ce sera très grave on est ok
allez hue aller parle moi de galenica il
est incroyable qu'est ce que tu veux que
je te dise et l'exceptionnel john
williams a three ndic santa clara
parcours assez assez complet petite
révélation en fin de saison une cote qui
montent beaucoup on avait vu un
potentiel défensif ou notamment sur pick
and roll qui l'avait défendu plus petit
que lui et moi je suis vraiment hyper
surpris par sa capacité à naviguer balle
en main par rapport à ce qu'il a montré
à la fac où ils avaient déjà beaucoup
ballon en main mais qu'on voyait une
main gauche assez faibles on voyait peu
de changements de direction peu de
changements de variations de rythme peu
de peu de variations de vitesse et je
suis plutôt adepte de dire que les
dribbles ça s'invente pas que ça se crée
pas assez rapidement nba que qu'il faut
quand même des bases solides john
williams arrive à me faire mentir très
rapidement entre ce qu'il a montré à la
fac ce qu'il a montré au combat une
année 12 55 est ce qu'il a montré l'an
summer league jouent un gars qui
progresse vraiment sur sa capacité à
créer du jeu balle en main de jour en
jour
dima gauche rythme bouloc et donc plus
ça va et plus je me dis que ce mec là on
l'a pas mis assez haut et je t'avais dit
une fois qu'ils avaient leur compétition
avec ousmane diagne le soir de la draft
que sa dette de profil un peu similaire
et koutiala nouvel obs me paraissait en
avance là-dessus alors ousmane s'est
blessé mais shane williams 9e je pense
qu'il peut être très vite titulaire
hockey ici où tout cas il peut vite
finir les matches dans une configuration
assez petit et vraiment je suis assez
rassuré sur sa capacité à exister au
niveau supérieur peu importe le rôle
qu'ils ont
c'était intéressant effectivement devoir
naviguer et aussi de voir progresser à
ce point alors que
pourquoi on l'avait pas mis seahawks à
c'est aussi parce que c'est un joueur
qui est âgé de
semaine dieng
ben si tu dois ajouter quelque chose sur
john williams sinon manche moi j'étais
très très
impressionné par sa capacité à finir au
cercle sa créativité son calme sa
capacité à prendre le contact c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment clé pour un gars
qui bossent genre un gros mélange
explosif qui peut finir par dessus le
monde d'être capable de se faufiler dans
des petits espaces de capable de créer
des choses à partir du contact puis il
le fait ce constamment de match hommage
oui
effectivement moi ça m'étonnerait pas
qu'il soit qui dégradent du temps de jeu
rapidement après ok si a resigné
kentridge williams qui est un peu un peu
moins porteur de balle mais quand même
dans le même profil
et donc tout ça nous fait dire que ce
maintien qui n'a passé une mauvaise
semaine ling qui n'ont pas fait une
extraordinaire
va plutôt jouer de la d-league les
prochaines minutes
il en a besoin il en a besoin ousmane
diagne le
l'urgence chez lui c'est de cette
prendre du coffre qu'ils ferment de
rendre compte de manière
structurée pour être capable de pour
être capable de presse blessés dans le
domaine dans métro les genoux non mais
sur les avions sur les articulations moi
je l' ai même pas vu assure me league
parce que je vais y était blessé les
matchs que je regarde
ut1 trucs sur dingue
ban est construite que ben la seule
chose qui m'a qui m'a plu c'est que en
une bielle il avait mis beaucoup de
temps à prendre des responsabilités à
prendre des tirs a osé faire des choses
et on avait vu un joueur qui était très
hésitant la houle hugo besson avait dit
bon ben vas-y jeu procès mon équipe et
je gagne et là il joue un ou deux
matches je crois et choix d un ou deux
matches il prend des pick and roll il
prend des tirs à trois points il prend
quelques poules up donc j'ai vu un jour
un peu plus agressif et je me dis que ça
c'est indispensable pour lui dans la
jungle ok si oui tout le monde veut
faire sa place et que tu as beaucoup de
bollène leur et de talent d'avoir cette
capacité à dire ok moi aussi je suis là
donc je croisais dans le jeu je trouve
que cette histoire et c'est pas une
romance qui me qui m'inspire haussmann
dieng a ok si messi donne les armes
c'est moins joli c'est une chance donc
c'est cool on a effectivement va falloir
être fort pour exister au milieu de tous
ces prospects se sont enfin du talent du
potentiel
un joueur que vous avez cités a donné du
fil à retordre cette équipe donc ici
kenny love theme junior jeu j'en ai
marre mais il faut en parler parce que
c'est vrai qu'il a été bon c'est vrai
tout ça fait deux ans à chaque fois
depuis le match contre la france
de 3 secondes dans la raclette c'est lui
sur la couverture de peu de la chronique
trois secondes raquette c'est mon kenny
dope tonnes qu'haïti qui amincit quand
même dans pendant cette année m6 et qui
est toujours
godinho comme on dit ici qu on peut
grâce rouillé quoi mais mais qui a fait
café qui a fait son taf pour cent
seulement
voilà est-ce que vous pensez qu'il va
jouer
je sais pas mais il a vraiment un skills
est très précis c'est un joueur beaucoup
plus gracieux que on pourrait le croire
c'est à dire qu'elle est capable de
finir au panier sur des gags beaucoup
plus grand et beaucoup plus long que lui
il l'avait fait sur victor une bannière
mans il le fait sur chat
je sais pas si ces jeux mass qui sait
faire et adapté à une réalité nba
moi je moi je suis dans son coin le
cheveu que je veux qu'il réussisse mais
ça y est vraiment une dextérité et une
habilité athlétique qui très
sous-estimées une question d'idées la
savoie avec lui ce qu'un tel que c'est
qui shoote il avait montré beaucoup de
touches et il a fait des bonds en a qui
sont rentrés c'était des miracles mais
il a mené cette attaque à trois points
il non mais c'est vrai c'était ça
prenons par rapport à son année un
dossier où il n'était pas non plus hyper
adroit il jouait plus près de pia déjà
louis déjà là jon jackson est blessé
aussi donc il est blessé pour genre vie
moi ou quelque chose du genre y ait
opéré puis il me semble qu'il
s'éteint tout est présent ouais ok
mais la question peut se poser c'est
offensivement d'accord on voit lui ce
qu'il est il est anachronique et
pourquoi des mecs comme c'est à vannes
ont eu des difficultés ce parce que
avoir un gars qui fait 20 cm de moins
que toi mais qui te bullish au centre de
gravité c'est horrible enfin c'est comme
avoir ton petit dans ton petit neveu ou
ton petit cousin qui 30 dans les jambes
ah ouais c'est chiant à ses chiens à
tenir et a pas l'habitude de maintenant
il défend qui pour l'instant gagné
l'open junior
pas grand monde
il ya un placement qui est pas mal mais
manquant même de protection ne sert qu'à
un manque de soutien bilité et avoir un
pivot backup offensif en nba c'est assez
rare il ya peu d'équipés qu'ils le font
la majorité c'est comme un quota qui
vous envoie sipho premier système de jeu
tu auras un tract est en poste 4
web et dans ce cas là dessus aussi car
défensivement quoi il faut que tu
compenses de l'autre côté maintenant ils
ont ils ont des mecs hyper intelligent
il ya un super coach à super système de
jeu mais à dd il ya des gens qui veulent
passer avant ya beaucoup de monde sur
ces postes-là brendon clark saviez de
telemann
sainte yal damas y joue un jour
donc
à essentielle damas il était clairement
au dessus du lot en pendant cette summer
league c'est pas un des joueurs dont on
a beaucoup parlé mais il finit à plus de
20 points par match trois
puissantes sans trop forcer quoi ni by
essentielle damas qu'on connaissait a
quitté la route il était super man il
est intelligent et prend des décisions
rapides touché très très soyeux sauront
panijel 50 très facilement et c'est un
jour ça change dans la tradition aussi
que une force que je connaissais pas
chez lui le secteur de sentir la
transition de donner des options à son
honneur ou à la personne qui va faire la
plonge dans lequel il était tout le
temps là d'un match que j'ai vu de tout
le temps partir une tradition à chaque
occasion récolté beaucoup way est
intéressant aussi de noter que c'est pas
un profil très alors du coup avec lofton
un peu plus mais des intérieurs avec
touchez pas non plus le truc le plus
répandu à m6 sans faire injure à xavier
thieman et brandon clark qui sont
achetés très bon défenseur que très
novateur c'est c'est contre philadelphie
je crois ou est-ce que xavier thieman
défendez jazz bass y est les deux gosses
elle est là c'est à trois points soyez
reculait de la dégoûtait ya chaque fois
que chaque fois qu'il est cela c'est
pour les trois points les gars avaient
un mépris pour le tir l'un de l'autre
a réussi à nous paraissait bien encore
après un je crois de la soirée sait même
plus qui va gagner le match mais ils en
ont pas mieux
est-ce que vous avez des choses à dire
sur l'utilisation ou la progression de
jay clara dia et david roddick sont les
deux forces pitt de sortir un pic de
même fils
jack lagrave ya été castée dans le rôle
de la biographie de danilo gallinari
même fissiles dans les matches que j'ai
vus il a extrêmement bien faire danilo
gallinari qui défont par contre oui oui
exactement c'est ce que j'allais dire il
beaucoup plus léger sur ses jambes que
gallinari et capable de se déplacer
latéralement mais on l'a mis dans des
coins
des vitraux dit aussi des vues de redire
je m'excuse des comme si jean crowder
avec une petite bedaine
il fait
des trucs vraiment plate sur le terrain
des branlées foulée truc vraiment dire
qu'aucun joueur faire comme pas d'époque
saout garder des joueurs en dehors de la
fête tous ces trucs là et à chaque fois
que cliquer sur le terrain son équipe
qui touche au ballon non son équipe
prend une montée le prend
1.15 et vicenza aussi super glisser un
mot sur canal j ai je dit beaucoup aimer
il
ils m'ont bien bavé physiquement par la
gelée même vu s'écrouler en un contre un
sur une possession offensif c'est à dire
qu'il y ait essayé essayé de passer sur
groupe qui a explosé au contact mais mes
joues à l'intérieur de ses moyens on
voit que c'est un leader on voit que
c'est un gars qui est capable de bien
placer ses gosses sur le terrain il est
de tirer sur les peintures offensivement
et défensivement aussi dans les lignes
de passe à chaque match je les ai vus je
crois que j'ai joué deux matchs oui
on a joué il a quasiment toujours aimé
il sortait du bon son mais non la seule
le seul joueur drafté sauternais que je
trouvais absolument catastrophique c'est
le bon vince williams
et ben ça me fera ça donnera de l'eau
content il ay la fed et comme d'habitude
ses stats les protégés de serre qu'il a
fait des styles et cd stoxx gilliam si
c'est la sûreté je fais je crée
l'événement des 106 je serais curieux de
voir son box klaus meine pour les
pour les la summer league parce que pour
marc sûr que c'est dans le négatif l'aïe
a perdu des ballons
c'était désorganisé comme jeu ça m'a
rappelé la dernière fois que j'ai dit
aussi horrifiés en garde un joueur c'est
quand les bucks avec joe alexander 8e
assemblée s'est passé à 4 virginie h
face s'est dit
tu me verrais tu as les yeux que tu
serais bien plus horrifié que de voir
joe alexander c'est comme si tu me
voyais total les yeux que tu serais bien
plus
c'est clair mais mais c'est le gars
était de racheter 8e puis tu le vois tu
le vois jouer ensemble et que tu te
rends compte qu'ils aient pas au niveau
du tout là j'avais en plus ce même
feeling là avec venus williams
6 pas capables si pas capable de gérer
une procession sans perdre le ballon
en somme ligue ça va être à 22 ans
et peut-être qu'on a trouvé le gars que
kanye d'enstone peut garder à
l'entraînement
[Rires]
jeudi l'ofs de
12-5 et nous souhaitons
une des choses à ajouter sur les crises
pas non du tout je trouve que ça te fait
un très très bon résumé donc j'ai pas
dire de bêtises en plus une équipe très
très agréable à regarder comment il
gérait sa bosse bien
j'ai beaucoup aimé aussi je savais que
tchèque klara vie est un des chouchous
j'ai bien aimé son utilisation il n'y
avait pas il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
shoots mais ici en accommode bien parce
qu'il sent si je les ai mis tout ce
genre est ce genre je pense qu'elle est
les matchs je regardais y avait 75 % à 3
points il ya des trucs ils ont un peu
sûr hélas le départ de ken anderson je
pense que d'ailleurs williams et à
prendre une plus gros rôle mais que j'ai
clara via c'est une draft qui va aller
ch pour remplacer notre ami n 2
c'est c'est un bon point 0e si
physiquement qui a absolument
voilée par dessus la summer league là il
était énorme il était partout je sais
pas encore qu'est-ce qui peut foire
systématiquement mieux que tout le monde
apporte défendre non mais
mais je le dis lol la base assez solide
pour développer au moins 1 ce qu'il aime
bien qui va être sa carte de visite
autre
satisfaction de la summer league du côté
de dean diana
bénédicte mathurin je vous l'avais pas
mis dans le programme
mais vous je sais que hughes a vu des
matchs de dean diana
le biberon à 3h du mat 4h 5h du mat si
tu regardes un peu tout ce qui se passe
ajoute
avec les cris et les mineurs tout pour
éviter les rediff de
documentaires animaliers sera
ben mathurin a été efficace pendant
cette scène des
combats violents des indiana
mendy au début et peut-être un peu plus
et c'est sur le peut-être un peu plus ce
qu'il a montré des choses assez
rassurantes
de base c'est que moi je n'étais pas un
grand fan de bd et mathieu coûte que de
l'image que que le joueur avait de
lui-même j'avais peur qu'ils se voient
qu'ils voient trop beau balle en main et
j'aime le fait qu'il deviendrait et
réussit à le convaincre tout de suite de
dire tu vas être un excellent joueur
loin du ballon et tu va tout exploser
lorsque filera valentin il a vraiment
été hyper appliquer là dessus il n'a pas
forcé n'a pas perdu trop de ballons
comme je pouvais le voir il a passé de
trop deux de faire de pick and roll en
tant que passeur et c est là que c'était
pas son basket je les trouvais bien plus
agressif au panier c'est même la summer
league mais j'avais un joueur qui
voulait pas se faire mal alors autant
défensivement je trouve qu'il a toujours
pas envie de se faire mal mais il est
allé au cercle pas que quand il y avait
une ligne ouverte pour mettre un gros
dunk mais il est allé au contact il a
fini avec la faute et il a réussi aussi
à se créer un peu plus d'écart show du
poulet trois points et ça ça met il pas
décisif pour lui parce qu'il va être au
départ s'ils voulaient comme un jour de
course loin du ballon et si peu posé le
dream créé année car cette step step
back tourner autour de end of etc ça m'a
vraiment le rendre encore plus efficace
et je suis vraiment hyper content de du
mariage en train de se faire entre le
projet et soeurs l'image qu'ils ont de
même nature en est ce que le joueur fait
c'est vraiment un début très prometteur
en plus du trade de broc donne qui va
lui donner encore plus d espace pour
s'exprimer même s'il y aura un playmaker
en moins bon tu devras flemmarde qui a
fait une bonne semaine ligue aussi qui
sait toujours pas shooter mais qui
sait faire tourner une équipe
et ben mathurin ce que tu disais c'est
important pour pas qu'ils deviennent
robben matelots morts
c'est à dire savoir faire des side step
et alleo certes c'est c'est exactement
ce qui va faire la différence parce que
honnêtement au tir je pense que c'est je
pense que c'est le meilleur shooteur
on parle et au moment où la saison va
commencer
il est extraordinaire il le tire par qu
enfin en tire quatre chaînes shoot pour
l'instant mais même il a commencé à
développer une diversité mais catch and
shoot il est imparable quoi c'est à dire
que mon tu sais tu vois ta cette
sensation de caen là le ballon arrive
vers lui et que tu le vois planter ses
appuis tu dis c'est dedans
parce que c'est toujours le même shoot
parce que c'est donc il ya quand même ce
truc assez rare d de confiance dans le
tir
autre autre chose dont on voulait parler
aujourd'hui
new orleans je notais n'y aura en ligne
c'est pourquoi j'ai vu
je sais bien mais c'était pour que
hugues face à un shoot à
je te laisse faire un stade pour ceux
qui ont une chance de jouer l'année
prochaine
cet excédent on peut on va commencer par
le plus évident c'est que ce choix et ma
fille a fait une très grande summer
league sophomore qui sortait du virginia
un parcours assez long qui était destiné
à être swing dit en nba et on lui a dit
essaye de montrer plus sur un ou deux
matchs et il a montré plus il a montré
de la création du team l'agressivité au
cercle à la trash talk du coup il a pas
du tout défendu que boldin g lui a
rappelé en disant c'est bien tu as mis
25 points mais t'as pas du tout défendu
la seule chose c'est que je pense que
c'est pas réaliste pour lui il y aurait
une billets parce que tu auras dire
beaucoup de bollène l'heure donc c'est
bien d'avoir montré ce que tu pouvais
faire mais il le fera pas au niveau au
niveau supérieur
après ça effectivement il y avait mon
gars d une si bonne qui je pense doit
être détestable vu que son coach en
summer league lui donne pas le ballon
donc si t'as pas le ballon en summer
league alors que c'est ta seule qualité
c'est que vraiment tu dois être un trou
du cul donc c'est très inquiétant pour
la suite de sa carrière qui peut déjà
bientôt s'arrêter à mon plus grand dam
et on a vu un john butler famélique
littéralement tout maigre qui a pas
jouer avant la toute fin de la summer
league alors il a fait un match à 6 sur
6 à trois points ce que john butler fait
très très bien mais on n'a pas de prise
de masse on a un joueur qui est une
dernière option de summer league donc
c'est pas vraiment rassurant pour pour
son avenir et lui va bouffer de la
g-league il va bouffer tout court et et
j'espère que son morphotype pour
apprendre un petit peu parce que sinon à
part ça ils ont donné des ballons dans
les mains de la jim marshall je suis pas
le plus grand fan mais qui dans une
rotation une bille est donné dès lé
ballon dans les mains de j'ai plus
comment il s'appelle le mec d'auburn qui
était ma que j'ordonne bien l'impression
d'y jouer quarante minutes par match et
qui prenaient tous les tirs jets quelque
chose mais j'arrête harper mes amis via
l'ena
mais voilà une ancienne hic avril ajoute
une ayant des leaks à son bord les
légendes des next year un peu qui était
un tout et je crois qu'ils vont jouer
une minute one sonic all ways ni quand
c'est ça mais moi ils ne nous relisent
qui ne tague et enfin les mecs de chez
les fans de new orleans motech à chaque
mois sur dix ans ils ont joué 3 minutes
mais ils ont joué
j'étais content et
jusqu'au temps doux d'abord moi je fonce
je pense que le mieux pour les deux
alors peut-être pas john butler mais
clairement je pense que le mieux pour si
brawn se serait de montrer qu'il est
capable d'être énorme tu vois genre en
europe en eurocup des trucs comme ça +
qu'angie mick pascal chili est ce qu'il
va montrer tu vois il va avoir la balle
n'a pris l'europe un cépage tous qu'en
europe des valeurs
même si ça a changé un petit peu il y
avait une terme très bonne interview de
better cornali le français qui est allé
jouer dans l'équipe jim des nuggets
rappelle plus le nom
peut-être bien sûr gbagbo
mais il racontait il a joué pas mal de
matches il disait on commence enfin ça
on commence mais la g-league c'est
beaucoup plus fort que ce que les gens
pensent au niveau aussi de l'acceptation
du rôle les joueurs qui vont commencent
à comprendre que s'ils veulent aller en
nba il faut qu'ils rentrent dans la case
dans laquelle enfin qu'on a dessiné pour
eux
donc c'est un fait
le seul seule satisfaction pour lui le
seul truc c'est que de dire que il a
fait un match où la miss il a tiré 63.5
et sa grosse faiblesse en catch and
shoot l'anamis 3 sur 6 voilà c'est
peut-être une clé d'entrée parce qu'il
n'a pas défendu il défendra jamais je
pensais gala mais il a free et voilà ils
apprécient 3.4 tout sur un match on a
mis la moitié il va falloir que tu
puisse tirer un petit peu loin du ballon
sinon ça va être très très compliqué
pour lui même par mois des knicks
53e ans ça compte trois mc de les
vérifier oreca 53e la terre connaît
libère les knicks je crois que on était
venu un ingé ligne pour
donner le ballon faire confiance aux
jeunes parce que je crois que les jeunes
se sont un peu fait fait martelé la
confiance par tom thibodeau
les autres parce qu'il est est un peu
taillé une place dans la rotation avec
le blessé au genou et queen games il a
fait ce que ce que ce qui était supposé
faire en 2e de saison assure mélissa
faisait de dominer il a dominé il le
gérer la lata qui le gérait le tempo il
était capable de finir au panier ce qui
n'était pas nécessairement une de ses
forces l'année dernière je crois que
justement athlétiquement parlant c'était
un peu compliqué il y avait aussi que
ricco sims qui l'a beaucoup aidé notre
beau et jéricho qui était un monstre
lors de l'incroyable hold you indien
thériault faire aller ou pas ensemble et
kuendig wise avait dit sur sur twitter
et qu'il y avait 10 j'étais
convaincue d'avoir lancé le ballon
beaucoup beaucoup trop tôt puis thierry
conserve c'est d'aller chercher derrière
est absolument des fonds si riche et si
vous a été un monstre défensivement
aussi et le loc dong jeunes attendent
comme une gueule quand ils ont joué les
gars ont joué
une excellente troisième option avec
l'élection d'un contrat de quatre ans ce
jeune maruge une place avec l'équipe
contre quatre
coins du golfe a bien défendu aussi mais
je crois que si on s'entend tous
ceux qui osent très intéressant parce
qu'il avait comme un peu pas de rôle
tous qui sait faire et fr un peu par
quelqu'un d'autre sur le terrain mais et
qu'il n'était pas un rythme n'était pas
capable d'avoir cédé des tirs qui
avaient du bon sens mais il est toujours
influencé les matchs positivement avec
son petit making il est toujours trouvé
une manière fois qu'il ya des deux de
deux façons de faire arriver quelque
chose avec son petit making soit
défensivement ou offensivement
ce qui est la marque d'un bon joueur de
rose c'est la mc2 mon rôle est donc ça
va être deux sur wii u il me parle de 12
may cry g
je ne saisis pas combien de matches de
vue moi je les ai tous vus sauf un
c'était bien mais c'était pas
c'était bien mais ce n'était pas aussi
convaincant que cela répondait dû être
du smic prime moi j'ai pas j'ai dû
trouver qui s'acquittaient bien des
tâches de meneur mais qui a pas montré
exactement qui signifie physiquement ni
intellectuellement qui était capable de
planer au dessus de la
ligue
l'a produit
je sais pas peut-être sont-ils
l'échantillon est un peu court mais
c'est un excellent joueur défensif son
excellent jeu moins d'énergie il couvre
toujours tout le monde à 94 pièce qui
est vraiment très emmerdant j'ai encore
du coach ou pas ce qui est très
dur
mais
ouais non je souhaitais je prédis
convient que j'ai pas été emporté par le
talent de bazin
je trouvais que physiquement par la
haine qu'elle est là et s'il ya une
différence fondamentale entre michelle
robinson est ici aussi
la longueur
la longueur mitchell robinson est
extrêmement longs durée cosim et des
biens meilleurs écrans du rico samedi à
la ja il est bâti comme bain des
peignoirs est donc en train dé qui soit
il mais des images de très très bons
écrans alors que matthew robinson a
beaucoup de difficultés avec le timing
oui multi je pense qu'il ya en étions
entre les deux c'est qu'ils aiment et
qui a fait 86 et même si c'est un coach
pour y écouter grosses stars and see
zurich s'il était dans l'ombre de
maubeuge bat de mike turner de jackson
wade alors finalement d'être le pivot
même de son année où il est drafté
rignacois guan devant il y accueille
jones et finalement le meilleur des
trois c'est gérer quoi sims point le
moment et mister bean sony n'a pas eu ça
donc il ya un vrai dre formation
académique et tu sais que le mec il est
prêt quoi jouer et un que tu dis mais je
vais dire tout ce que ben a dit
on le voyait déjà à texas ian cusick
eric aussi s'est engagé à un des pivots
que j'ai vu jouer qui descend le plus
bas sur ses appuis pour aller pour aller
ensuite glissé avec les arrières et
c'est extraordinaire de mobilité
d'explosivité
oh et puis c'est ça qui fait ce qui fait
c'est super simple mais le fait subir ça
a été ça a été l'année dernière en nba
pour du riz quotium un travail
d'adaptation qui était aidé par des
blessures
parti à taj gibson qui n'a pas été le
signe et saint sernin pour pour laisser
de la place à jabbeke aussi dans
l'alignement mais cette adaptation là
elle est faite je crois justement qu
avec
robinson runtime et sims ont nos droits
trois pivots avec trois profils
différents qui vont être capable de
changer le match mais ce que je veux
dire ce que je voulais dire par ma
question c'est que pour moi la
différence de salaire et justifient pas
la différence de niveau
peut-être de potentiel
ces cinq années c'est le premier rookie
prolongé par les knicks depuis
1970 croit
1994 en appel on appelle ça la
malédiction de thaliba
maintenant on appellera ça la
bénédiction des
voitures
qui nous manque dans le programme il
nous manque
ouais charlotte bas vu que charles
autres un peu tout et souvent presque
ac tout décevant
on a trois constats tirés je pense mark
williams on nous a vendu un pivot près
et c'est s est justifié par rapport à
prendre gnl du renne ben non il n'est
pas très parce que l'inadaptation
physique tu vas devoir faire et ça va
mettre du temps elle va falloir être
patient avec ce joueur et c'est pas lui
qui va être le pivot titulaire des
roannais qui vont les amener en playoffs
très vite puisque des problèmes
actuellement judiciaire les ronettes
sont pas de bol
deuxième bilan cahier de jonsi fin
premier match lui prend 8,3 points avec
une mécanique de tir capté retravailler
mais qui a été détruite et donc il fait
1 à 0 sur 8 dramatique witi rappela et
ses horribles et ensuite démâté après il
joue près du cercle et on retrouve cet
intérieur trop mobile capable de mettre
des euros step capable de finir avec
dédé tir acrobatique adm acrobatique et
de dominer et ça ça fait kiffer et d'eti
sort c'est un athlète formidable mais
pour l'instant ces cas là tu est
formidable donc le projet semble un peu
court et je suis très déçu de pas avoir
vu gentoo knight ses passions pour
blesser ou non il est jeune il a un
plâtre son legs
ça sent pas bon pour james hook après
ça sent pas bon pour kyle jones non plus
franchement après ça ça sent pas bon
pour mark williams non plus si mike
williams qui a levé un physique et dès
qu'ils sont fous son physique ce dès sa
carte de visite
si son physique est pas prêt je dire
quelles valeurs il apporte à part de
faire tourner les serviettes sur les
banques
moi je t'aime je trouvais que la rai
pour au tour de mike williams était
complètement injustifiée et je pense que
je pense qu'il tombe dans une situation
[Musique]
en cours de saison et nous on l'a on l'a
plutôt mou dans ces eaux là à la fin
aussi il était dans le groupe avec avec
kamagaté avec le faire kessler avec tous
ses grands compas une énorme valeur
ajoutée mais protège au moins deux
certes en groupe
rail après il ya eu neuf qui a été créée
par le fait qu'ils jouent à duke déjà
quand même et puis et puis l'adresse aux
lancers francs qui est important pour
moi c'était quand même le prospect plus
intéressante que ce groupe là par sa
espèce de toucher voir un joueur que tu
peux laisser sur le terrain à la fin de
match parce que il tenait des fêtes
mais effectivement la summer league n'a
pas
pas été un succès pour lui on termine
avec vos enjoy petit stand out on en a
déjà cité plusieurs lors de l'épisode 1
notamment tomic ouzou
est quand même extraordinaire
ben est ce que tu rotana déjà cité dans
l'autre épisode est ce que tu en as
trouvé d'autres bains j'aimerais juste
et un jour alors qu' on n'a pas parlé
qui été drafté par exemple cette année
jilin jay leno les rockets qui a été qui
était merveilleux qui est exactement le
joueur que je croyais qu'il était c'est
à dire lorsqu'on lui l'ont lâché
lorsqu'il n'est pas au centre de
l'attaqué d'une équipe c'est un joueur
qui est mobile se joie qu'il faisait ils
ne sont pas très haut ce qui va ce
qu'ils vont faire qu'il va gérer ils
auront des problèmes comme finisseur
oui et ce qui je crois qu'il va devenir
joe schmidt loi partie plus plus enviée
et
pour l'instant je me tiens ma prédiction
très bien tauch marc roberts
et c'est quoi ce ciseau rivia pas moins
une
vingtaine d'années parce qu'on en avait
parlé colling il est si j'ai pas sinon
voilà on n'a pas cité dans les salles
avec eux avec denver kimbaseke ce qui va
faire on en a parfois toute l'année
alors il va jouer ce week-end 10 jours
les postes arrières à une biais il bouge
très bien et défend très bien très
intelligent tir haut qui rendent % à 3
points je pense que tu perds mon de thé
maurice tu l'as signant tout et je pense
que voit ce mec là il peut jouer à côté
d'eux nicolaï au kit sans aucun problème
et s'intégrer parfaitement dans le
système de denver donc
drafted j'aime beaucoup et après on
sophomore viendra peut-être falloir que
je trouve qu'il a bien performé cette
année il ya des vies juke qui a été
plutôt pas mal avec eux
lynette et jeu très inquiète par contre
pour y font ce qui est allé avec les
nets ceci et
je comprends pas bien ce joueur alors on
parle du tir à trois-points ya plein de
mecs n'ont pas un tir à trois points
can't catch renders built on doit
laisser personne chose comme ça comment
un jour aussi intelligent défensivement
aussi athlétique ne n'arrive pas à
trouver un un spot en nba et on parle
peut-être d'un retour en europe pour
yves et voilà j'étais excité le fait de
le voir avec les nets est un peu
inquiète un peu déçu
ben t'as vu les net's aussi un oui
c'était un peu une équipe de son mailing
fait pour une équipe de ligue américaine
thomas sky et kim thomassin walker et
caisse claire edouard ce qu'ils sont
deux joueurs qui vont jouer en ligue 1
oui oui clairement parce qu'on peut
choisir plus personne mais sinon
j'allais jallet nommé victimes évitent
creech été drafté nom wii
qui je crois qu'il qui a fait une super
surmely l'espèce de
qui shoote
jours les joueurs de hockey
qui qui qui trouvera oui mais il ya
demandé le ballon souvent sur le terrain
c'est vraiment lui qui était qui prenait
les responsabilités qui ne chute pas
vraiment mais qui souffre toujours une
manière de se sortir des problèmes et la
connexion avec mon autre
c'était un super pouvoir des idées
de toujours être en vue du portant le
ballon spécialement kind of trouble
c'est vrai il est il est toujours il est
toujours dans le portrait
prise à 3
moi moi moi moi ça moi ça me dit merci
beaucoup les machos qui s'ils arrêtent
summer league comme dans la com d'agglo
je suis déçu je suis déçu vous n'ayez
pas cité scottie pippen junior
ouais ouais ouais j'ai trouvé qu'il
avait été exactement comme
comme j'attendais
son utilisation
rogers à toronto si
tu papale dans le moule
mais j'ai trouvé les deux to wait des
lakers dans l'ensemble bien choisi
scottie pippen junior caire joueur qui a
montré pour le coup là il avait là fait
moins de responsabilités offensives donc
il a pu montrer que en défense il est
solide ce qu'on savait et il abat règle
a pas perdu de ballons il a fait jouer
son équipe il était vraiment plus mature
que les autres sur le terrain ça se
voyait et puis cole sneijder est un
joueur de 2008 qui tirent très très très
bien donc de par conséquent il a une
possibilité d'un jour voire des minutes
on a une vie là où max christian galéré
avec
l'actrice qui a galéré mais on a vu
qu'il est intelligent moi je les ai vus
sur la première summer league la lacelle
de
et c'était et c'était pas si mal tu vois
c'est sûr qu'à côté de en phase ii d'un
kim johnsson c'est difficile de faire la
comparaison 3000 da 3 en deux mois mais
il est long fin physiquement il n'était
pas il n'était pas à la rue pâle max
christie faut qu'il rende ses cheminées
pareil pour avoir tant de joueurs m'ont
donné mais défensivement j'y crois et
vous connaissez le ferrari de sacramento
c'était exceptionnel
francky ferrari nord gp
ferrari son nom de famille mais je crois
que tu es tranquille tirage et je rigole
quand c'est possible et qui détient à
propos du milieu de terrain et les
voyelles et les fans du king sur twitter
mode mais arrête et après au lieu ni les
roues le génie pas vraiment c'était
incroyable c'est parce que j'aimerais ça
m'a régalé
les journaux alors oui exactement funky
ferrer il s'appelle qui est déjà super
non en qui faire bloc
qui travaillent
à bonal mais moche
il jouait il jouait à zaragosa
la vaillance et cela il est incroyable
ah oui à jouer il a joué pour les oies
rieuses de santa cruz dont dieu sinon
c'est un bon gars
commencent et c'est là c'est la fin de
la somalie
une remarque avant qu'on se quitte
messieurs une envie en mots à faire
passer
c'est fut très très agréable encore pour
toutes les bonnes et les mauvaises
raisons
c'est du mans on retournera s devant nos
écrans pour lacer merolli 2023
on le voulait pour m photo c'est
peut-être quand il sera en la personne
de la crise et on espère avoir de choix
parce que
même 3 qui ferrari je pense que il me
cross tous les jours
tu vas tu vas prendre les rebonds à
l'échauffement des
jets servir de ballons c'est sûr
allez prenez soin de vous tout le monde
et on vous retrouve bientôt pour des
podcasts sur les championnats
fiba jeunes puisque oyonnax plein plan
là on a eu le 17 on a on va avoir les
u18 on a eu bon les u20 ont fait une
haie mais voilà on a plein de choses à
dire sur les jeunes français et
internationaux il ya du beau monde
généralement ses compositions des vos
prospects il joue à tous ciao
[Musique]